bonsoir
[Musique]
moi c'est bien
je suis debout devant vous et pourtant
j'aurais dû arriver ce soir en fauteuil
roulant il a fallu que je me relève
je suis là ce soir pour vous parler
de mon invisible avec lequel je suis né
nous sommes nés à deux j'ai une sœur
jumelle Isa
nous sommes des jumelles miroirs Isa et
Béa
et c'est grâce à cette invisible que je
suis là avec vous ce soir
quand vous êtes venus ce soir au TEDx
vous avez passé une ligne solution dans
mes techniques on dit toujours
consciemment vous pouvez vous laisser
aller le travail est inconscient et je
demande à l'inconscient de garder
uniquement ce qui est bon et utile pour
vous moins vous comprenez mieux ça
fonctionne tout seul rien d'autre à
faire que de laisser faire
mes techniques utilisent des ressources
inconscientes celles qui sont invisibles
et c'est grâce à cela oui grâce à cela
que je suis là debout vivante et
tellement heureuse de partager cela avec
vous il y a ce qui est visible et ce qui
est invisible
et la confusion est une grande ressource
dans laquelle j'ai pu puiser des
solutions
et la confusion elle a toujours fait
partie de ma vie parce que dès le départ
nous étions deux dans la famille il y
avait papa maman et Claire notre grande
sœur et tel un séisme cataclysme un
tremblement de terre
nous sommes passés de trois à cinq
oui j'ai une sœur jumelle et mon mari et
bien lui aussi les jumeaux oui c'est un
jumeau c'est assez particulier parce que
ce qui fascine chez les jumeaux
c'est le trouble et la confusion que
cela induit alors
comment maîtriser l'invisible
[Musique]
comment comprendre cette énergie ce lien
d'amour inconditionnel comment lorsqu'on
est né unique avoir cette confiance
cette assurance que les jumeaux
renvoient
comment toucher palper sentir cette
force qui émane du couple gémellaire
la sécurité et la reconnaissance c'est
ce que le cherche l'être humain tout au
long de sa vie et les jumeaux incarnent
cela dans l'inconscient collectif jamais
ils ne seront seuls sur terre
on dit que quand on vient au monde on
cherche son âme sœur
cette théorie de l'âme sœur on peut la
retrouver dans le Banquet de Platon à
l'origine les êtres humains avaient
quatre bras quatre jambes et une seule
tête à deux visages et Zeus qui aurait
craint leur pouvoir les auraient coupées
en deux aurait secoué la terre et les
aurait condamnés à chercher tout le long
de leur existence la part manquante mais
quand on est né à deux son âme sœur est
déjà là tout est plus simple
rien
ne nous bloque par rapport à l'extérieur
oui
je suis né à deux
et ce lien invisible
ce lien invisible qui a toujours été une
force
qui a toujours permis à ce que l'on soit
on crée dans un invisible
nous a permis de vivre des choses
complètement incroyables
que personne ne comprenait
il y a une de mes collègues qui restait
pendant
des semaines à ne plus m'adresser la
parole à me faire la tête j'ai rien
compris je suis allé la voir je lui ai
dit bah qu'est-ce qu'il y a qu'est-ce
qui se passe comment ça qu'est-ce qui se
passe tu te moques de moi tu étais au
restaurant à la table à côté
tu m'as pas dit bonjour tu m'as blousé
toute la soirée et en plus tu as
embrassé un autre homme que ton mari
vous le savez quand même que j'ai une
sœur jumelle je dispense une formation
on me dit que je suis cass contact je me
précipite à la pharmacie et là je
demande à faire un test elle me regarde
elle me dit bah non vous c'est interdit
mais comment ça c'est interdit ben non
vous êtes venu il y a un quart d'heure
vous étiez négatif et là je comprends
qu'ils a été cas contact quel est allée
dans la même pharmacie que moi il a
fallu que je sorte ma pièce d'identité
pour justifier de qui j'étais
la confusion le fait de ne pas
comprendre
de pas maîtriser cette invisible alors
qu'on a la même voix qu'on se ressemble
qu'on a tout pareil les mêmes types de
langage les mêmes capacités
tout semble pareil en même temps à
l'opposé
lorsqu'on était adolescentes Isa avait
une kiné
qui lui parlait des marques qu'elle
avait dans son corps des marques de
fractures visa disait moi j'ai jamais eu
de fracture c'est Béa qui a une fracture
à la cheville pourtant vous en avez les
marques
on allait chez le dentiste moi j'avais
une carie à droite elle avait la même
dent Carrié à l'opposé
nous sommes des jumelles miroirs et à
chaque fois qui nous est arrivé quelque
chose dans la vie l'autre en avait en
avait l'empreinte dans son corps
et cette kiné elle a voulu nous emmener
à Paris
pour nous étudier et montrer à quel
point
la gemilité pouvait avoir
d'étranges dans ce que provoquer les
marqueurs inconscients dans le corps de
l'autre
la gemilité c'est très flou ça attire
et en même temps ça intrigue les gens
veulent savoir veulent comprendre mais
en fait il y a rien d'autre à faire que
de laisser faire
et c'est comme une magie oui comme de la
télépathie à ne pas savoir si cette
sensation
m'appartient ou lui appartient
et même la douleur qui passe de l'une à
l'autre
ce monde magique
cette force
est formidable mais le jour où
ça devient un handicap
ce fantasme cette sécurité d'être
peut se transformer en drame
j'ai eu un accident
je suis resté plusieurs années dans un
fauteuil roulant et j'ai fait plus de 12
ans 230 douleurs
et ce lien invisible
qui nous reliait qui a toujours été une
force incroyable
qui nous a permis de dépasser des
limites
de vivre les choses vraiment sommet nous
a transporté
dans un monde de douleur
de noirceur
et d'incompréhension
il a fallu trouver des solutions
des ressources
et quand on fait de la PNL de la
programmation neuro-linguistique quand
on a été formé à l'école de Palo Alto on
sait que forcément quelque part dans le
monde quelqu'un a vécu la même chose que
nous
alors j'ai commencé à chercher des
modèles de personnes qui avaient trouvé
leur solution à visionner des TEDx des
ressources inconscientes d'autres
possibilités
afin de permettre à Isa de vivre mon
handicap sans le subir
à chercher des personnes qui
interagissent sur ce lien invisible
des personnes qui nous mettent un
interrupteur
afin de permettre à Isa
de vivre
sans avoir à subir toutes mes douleurs
mes souffrances
à un moment donné
il a fallu que
je lâche tout ce que je croyais laisser
la vie faire
et trouver des ressources inattendues
invisibles
grâce à un magnétiseur qu'on a pu
interagir sur ce lien
afin qu'ils aient ne soit plus victime
de mes soins car lorsque j'étais en
centre antidouleur quand j'étais à
l'hôpital en son de rééducation à chaque
fois quelqu'un me touche et me manipuler
elle ressentait au plus profondément
les mêmes souffrances
ces au-delà de nous deux
que j'ai trouvé
alors dans mon inconscient
des ressources auxquelles je n'avais pas
où peut accès
car dans le mot impossible moi j'ai
toujours entendu les 80% de possibles
ces ressources inconscientes cet amour
inconditionnel ce lien invisible mon
permis d'aller chercher à l'intérieur de
moi-même
et de décider de solution
[Musique]
je savais beaucoup plus de choses que je
savais que je savais
ce que disait toujours Melton Ericsson
vous savez plus de choses que vous savez
que vous savez et moi il a fallu que je
comprenne que je pouvais avoir accès à
tout cela
je vais vous dire en quelques mots le
début de l'histoire le début d'un
cauchemar
le début de l'enfer
soudain au réveil d'une opération tout
bascule
plusieurs années en fauteuil roulant on
m'avait dit tu ne marcheras pas
et tu n'auras jamais d'enfants
et pourtant
je suis là avec vous ce soir debout
ce qui m'a permis de dépasser mes
douleurs
c'est cette capacité qui avait Isa de
ressentir tout ce que je ressentais en
effet lorsque j'étais hospitalisée elle
pouvait m'appeler le matin en me disant
j'ai été réveillé soudainement cette
nuit et au même moment moi j'étais
traversée
par des coups de couteau
des douleurs chroniques
et elles savaient
lorsqu'elles se réveillait comme cela
que ça n'était pas elle mais moi
elle savait mieux que quiconque ce que
Jean durait
une nuit à l'hôpital
il y avait une atmosphère étrange
j'avais des douleurs insurmontables
j'étais plus ma copine et j'avais pu
envie
et là
dans un élan de survie
j'ai trouvé une ressource qui m'a sauvé
j'ai eu l'impression de pousser d'ouvrir
les portes de l'invisible grâce à la
force de ma soeur Isa l'amour de ma
famille de mes amis
c'est ce qui a révélé ce que je suis
aujourd'hui
[Musique]
j'ai montré à la vie
qui je suis droit dans les yeux
chercher dans l'invisible oui chercher
dans l'invisible c'était à la fois la
sauver et me sauver
trouver des ressources invisibles afin
de marcher à nouveau
trouver un nouvel équilibre
continuez à vivre
à travers l'autre sans la bloquer
ni l'entraver
paradoxalement le jumeau miroir qui
lorsque tout bascule ne peut vivre sans
handicaper l'autre il a fallu trouver
des personnes qui coupent ce lien de
douleur afin de permettre à l'autre de
vivre sans subir
il a fallu que je libère Isa pour me
libérer
oui
je suis née à deux
et je suis devenue quatre
il y a d'abord eu Stéphane
et un gynécologue un peu barjot
qui nous a permis
de nous accompagner dans cette aventure
et il y a eu
Marie
notre bébé miracle
et puis après Eugénie notre deuxième
bébé miracle
merci à la vie d'être ce que je suis
aujourd'hui
une maman comblée une femme debout
en fait rien d'autre à faire que de
laisser faire
merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]